[Music]
[Applause]
uh please join me virtually in welcoming
catherine ry jewell thank you
okay yeah make sure everybody can hear
me and as i enunciate
about college radio all right so
hopefully that is sharing so that you
can all see the party the party ball
uh since i am starting in the 1970s
appropriately
maybe we'll go backwards a little bit
things setting up here
so we're going to start in 1978 perhaps
unsurprisingly as rumors of a call
letter change percolated through these
volumes or one volume of the book this
is a hardbound ledger kept in the wtbs
studio at mit in the basement of the
walker memorial building
where handwritten notes
about station announcements technical
problems conversations regarding station
affairs all aware
by wtbs's annual benefit in 1979
warnings surfaced not to mention
ted turner
on the air
but that the call letters might
transition to wnbr before that event and
thus two forms of promotional
announcements would be recorded for that
upcoming event
mit station had turned down the new york
times's 1973 petition for the letters
but turner's offer came at just the
right time
although the station had increased power
as the fcc was phasing out the class d
license popular at most college stations
on the fm non-commercial band it needed
another upgrade to prevent challenges
for its license from higher powered
stations
thus straining its budget
donations had also flagged and the
station received scant support from mit
given its independent license held by a
non-profit corporation
although it remained a student activity
which is why uh station positions such
as general manager
are required to be students
as one alum remembered out of the blue
turner contacted the station to buy the
call letters of course he remembered
buying call lego letters was not legal
but after negotiations it was agreed
that mr turner would donate 25 000 to
the radio station when it released its
call letters by acquiring new ones and
then he donated an additional 25 000
once wtbs became his
instead of wtbs standing for the
technology broadcasting system the new
letters wmbr would stand for walker
memorial basement radio that is the
check
in the book
in the studio
where it still resides
or maybe
i don't know
as the deal went forward
turner insisted that the station refrain
from using the call letters he has paid
for to avoid association between a
college station and his atlanta-based
broadcasting empire
the general manager cautioned announcers
not to inform listeners even those
calling in
of
the whole turner story
even though turner's fifty thousand
dollars classified as a gift
not as illegal payments for call letters
it didn't seem wise to dwell on the
transaction
finally the telegram announcing the
change arrived carter allen wrote that's
it wtbs has been nuked and no longer
exists
instead wnbr arose from the ashes
the official change took place on may
24th 1979 at 0 300 the hour all fcc
license changes take effect
staffers turned back to questions
regarding programming staffing and
making cambridge rock
turner's check
appeared in wnbr's coffers at a moment
when changes were gripping college radio
commercial broadcasting and higher
education
there's just a few listed here forgive
all of the text i got a little carried
away
there's the pacifica decision though
there's changes to the class d license
there's weakening public service
requirements for commercial broadcasters
such as they had been
as well as regulatory changes that would
embolden urban renewal efforts in the
corporatization of higher education
college radio garnered attention from
administrators political officials and
the music industry for reasons beyond
questions of obscenity or indecency or
political balance in broadcasting
subjects that often receive the lion's
share of attention to culture war era
battles over media and entertainment
given these developments
on the surface
turner's purchase of wtbs's call letters
seem to signal
the coming deregulation and
corporatization in media
for media scholars turner's empire
signaled consolidation and convergence
in that would transform entertainment
and in the 1980s and 1990s
thanks to faith in the concept of
synergy to choke out competition
thanks to revised antitrust enforcement
and rule changes regarding ownership and
licensing
college and community radio in this
rendering
seem like these stalwart
underdog defenders of democratic radio
and diverse voices against the
stultifying
middle road entertainment on offer from
corporate media and the record industry
which was intent on cramming disco and
arena rock or
as bruce shulman lamented in his history
of the 1970s the peter framptonization
of the music industry
the college radio
existed as part of the larger economy of
radio as well as within and in
relationship to the commercial music
industry to broadcast media
regulation
and to these institutions of higher
education
so what i suggest is that instead of
seeing these signals as simply authentic
democratic alternatives to these
developments
instead
needs to be understood as a site of
negotiation regarding these developments
in u.s media political economy and
popular and political culture
now perhaps this revised narrative
doesn't exonerate peter frampton for his
contributions to popular culture but
they do
put the history of stations like wnbr
into new perspective
so wmbr while it stands out among
college radio stations for its
independence from its host institution
nonetheless can't fully escape mit's
institutional logics
nor the ever-present challenges to
college radio's democratic potential and
contributions to american musical
culture
so to explore this dynamic since i'm at
mit talking about mwmbr i'm going to
take a little bit of an uncommon
approach for myself rather than kind of
traveling over the country i'm going to
use wnbr as a lens and give you three
episodes in its history with a little
epilogue uh to explore these
confrontations uh with these larger
historical source uh forces
so turning to episode one we're going to
go
back before the turner check for a
little bit
when wnbr then still wtbs
signaled how from the early days of
campus fm stations students connected
campus activism to community service
revealing how institutions of higher
education were embedded within
communities
so we're starting in boston where soul
music fans turned to college stations
after 1969.
a boston globe columnist described quote
the aridity of the am airwaves insofar
as consistent soul programming is
concerned he encouraged
readers to escape the assault of insipid
broadcasting by tuning into student-run
radio
boston university harvard boston college
emerson and tufts all offered a range of
black-oriented programs
harvard consistently programmed jazz
since the 1950s while emerson offered
the black experience northeastern aired
a show called seoul's place dedicated
specifically to that genre
but the columnist singled out one show
the ghetto
at mit for its quality
in 1969 mit's black student union
its chapter on campus had sought an
outlet on the campus radio station the
student activity
reflecting civil rights activism's turn
to cultural celebration and black power
in addition to a memphis sound program
and a throwback r b show on weekends
mit's station kept listeners sustained
with music unavailable on commercial
radio and there's a great write-up of
this program here on this website that i
have linked here so you can go and kind
of read read the full history that i'm
kind of pulling from here
so wtbs had eight watts when the ghetto
debuted but that increased to 720 by
1972 helped along by an mit trustee and
fcc member who smoothed the process
even with this still limited coverage
the signal reached into densely
populated areas
as the first engineer for the ghetto w
on sally pictured i think it's yeah
that's a picture this picture
um as he remembered
the number of shows and nightly
programming meant mit station became the
number one black radio station in the
entire boston metropolitan area i don't
know if this will play or not i don't
know if it will it will hold the zoom
but you can go on to and uh
on youtube
[Music]
i don't know how that sounded but
there we go there we go
uh
so the ghetto sets
mwtbs apart in the entire boston
metropolitan area for its programming
so mit's offerings amounted to more than
alternative musical entertainment
these shows together collectively helped
in uniting the black community the
former dj explained
the ghetto and the bsu offered local
national and international news
student djs designed programs to emulate
higher powered black oriented fm
stations in other markets hoping to
diversify the sound of the hub's
airwaves as sally remembered we became
like the number one station in boston i
mean black white everything
wtbs featured artists to promote local
appearances
pop entertainers such as the jackson
five jazz artists such as al jarreau
visited wtbs to record promos and give
live interviews
sully remembered visits by aretha
franklin richard pryor isaac hayes and
stevie wonder because as he put it if
you had any event that was going on in
boston that was black then you had to
get it on the ghetto because everyone
would hear it
in 1972 the ghetto hosted a concert by
war that attracted more than 20 000 fans
that event inspired ghetto djs to
imagine
my single favorite
instance in college radio history a city
party
the hub
at wmbr or wtbs excuse me
the ghetto essentially would broadcast
music to a party hosted outside the
station
then there would be satellite parties at
other area college stations that
rebroadcast
what the mit signal was putting out on
their low watt signal
together these 10 watt signals would
blanket the entire
region essentially
um
across greater boston
as sally described everybody in their
homes and cars were urged to turn on the
ghetto
and to play it loud you could stand
outside almost anywhere in the boston
metro area and hear the party people
were dancing in the streets there's
another newspaper article that describes
driving down streets in boston you could
hear parties in living rooms out on the
streets as people were tuning in all
across the area the event
importantly netted more than ten
thousand dollars in donations for the
station
the ghettos hosts moreover became
leaders of the station
unlike other institutions where students
found campus stations often to be closed
to black students and student leaders
mit proved different
a dj for the ghetto became wtbs's
general manager in 1971 sally became the
station's first licensed engineer along
a survey with serving as comptroller
mit station offered significant time to
programs for the area's black residents
with music and news tailored to their
interests
eventually commercial fm stations in the
market emerged to displace mit's status
as boston's leader in black music but it
remained an important spot on the dial
for seoul r b and reggae featuring both
student and community djs
institutional arrangements prove crucial
to this outreach
mit's governance structure allowed wtbs
the freedom to pursue community oriented
programming
although the station received
institutional support with its on-campus
space and qualified as a student
activity it enjoyed greater independence
from than other college stations
nonetheless
despite existing in an ecosystem
somewhat apart from commercial radio or
even from host institutions
non-commercial licensed stations still
worked within the broader structure of
broadcasting and the commercial music
industry
therefore i turn
to episode 2.
so in episode 2
we're moving on from city party which
indicated how college radio could offer
community service and culture
and defiance of commercial broadcasting
trends
still these links were strong with
commercial interests
college radio was becoming known as in
the music industry as a place to test
new sounds
signals support for new wave and post
punk after 1978 in particular show that
these signals could make waves in
popular music
but only a handful of independent labels
existed with most college stations still
relying on major labels or major label
distribution for the music they played
along with the fcc
labels privileged higher wattage signals
in major markets that could reach many
listeners on a single frequency
providing an existential threat to small
under finance stations that were facing
budget cuts thanks to declining
enrollments and state funding
so these college stations
they could drive sales in certain genres
and demographics in certain markets
aristo records for example for one
enjoyed a very good relationship with
college stations as its jazz records
including those by gil scott herron
received play on many college signals
but those good relations gave way to
dismay
among college djs in 1979 as major
labels began cutting back on college
promotions
inflation economic recession in the late
70s hit the music industry
and labels cut this promotional staff
billboard reported in august 1979 that
college radio is entering a crucial
stage with many stations in jeopardy of
being cut off from free record company
service
a m records which for 10 years staffed a
dedicated college radio promotion team
abruptly axed that wing
rca
mca electra asylum all cut staff who
focus on promoting to the college crowd
as album-oriented radio the commercial
format left behind its freeform days for
stations like wbcn in boston
the industry
the radio industry and the music
industry welcomed the data-driven
approach of these new commercial formats
that made financial sense and hard times
labels could ill afford to send records
to
college stations where they would gather
dust on shelves during the summer for
example
so it was labels financial woes that
accounted for the decision not any sort
of perceived shift in college radios it
was too weird or too out there or
something like that
executives focused on stations that
proved they could make waves in the
market
to receive free records stations had to
show that they could break new artists
that they could drive sales at record
stores and provide that data back to the
labels
so stations amateurism often fragment
and it's fragmented schedules in these
block programs
which you'll see some images of that
that worried these promoters who were
increasingly cognizant of their bottom
lines
so by summer of 1980 and uh if you can
see this is just the beginning uh of
what's about to happen um by the summer
of 1980 wmbrs realized that their record
service was in jeopardy
one dj attention called uh
called them the record manure people he
spelled it this way in the book
uh i felt i had to spell this out for
you uh and
he he pointed to distributors who cut
off the air supply to non-com fm's
he suggested dj's contact those disc
heads on high the book is amazing for
direct quotes i like can't stop quoting
um
it's like it's like ridiculous um
contact those disc heads on high with
the campus perspective
dj's debated you know they're just a
small watt station they're one of many
uh
so they're thinking about how to combine
their power with other stations to
protest these changes
arista records was the one that's going
to emerge as the prime target regarding
its record service fee but that it
wasn't the only one
that wmbr djs targeted for boycotts and
they were sort of a subset uh within
this larger arista boycott which i won't
go super into
instead
i'm going to focus on this
subset issue in 1980 uh you have british
independent labels rough trade and
beggars banquet signing new wave and
post punk group such as joy division
which i wore the t-shirt see ubiquitous
and college radio uh buzzcocks
uh and the raincoats
miles copeland iii manager for squeeze
and for his brother's band the police
launches irs records for which he
crafted an innovative promotional plan
he secured distribution from jerry moss
ahead of a m with this deal he brought
the buzzcocks to the united states and
he relied
on college radio
as nbr djs noted the small new wave
label signed many acts broken by the
station
wmbr played the buzzcocks as well as the
cramps which had released independent
singles before signing with irs
but when irs instituted a 25
fee for records sent to non-commercial
stations the djs were baffled
the music director told label wraps the
station was just not going to pay this
fee
not only did he balk at the sun
he considered it a betrayal
we feel he explained the fee placed an
unjustified burden on a station that has
supported them
he asked djs to refrain from playing new
irs records until the label rescinded
the charge
a dj responded seems like the irs is
indeed living up to their name
see what i mean
irs had yet to release its first number
one record in 1981 of course the go-go's
beauty and the beat which would top
challenge radio charts on its way to
commercial success and mtv
peter buck still worked at athens
wextree records and had only just met
michael stipe their band rem
would sign to ris and define college
rock
but in 1980 that success linked to
college radio
had yet to establish the label's might
and the medium's influence
wmbr's djs believed irs depended on
non-commercial stations not vice versa
i love this picture of them they're very
very young
nonetheless
these stations lacked collective clout
with industry publications such as
college media journal only having just
recently appeared to track college
charts in 1978
college radio is still kind of nascent
in being able to prove its industry
influence
irs too sought to establish its
reputation if stations had to pay for
record service it would be clear they
offered high quality music right what
you pay for things that are valuable
copeland wanted the credibility that
came with independence
and
the prestige afforded to major labels he
thought record fees were the way to do
this
for the majors bands featuring
synthesizers or more experimental sounds
still seemed like a passing fad
irs strove to legitimate the music
and college radio is important to that
but appearing as a major player took
precedence
wnbr's famed punk show the late risers
club began though a month-long boycott
months long as many months of irs
closing off a primary show on which its
artists would appear
while no meaningful larger boycott of
irs emerged the same was not true for
arista which most of these comments that
i have
drawn from a cmj editorial
are commenting about
for that record label a multi-station
boycott emerged centered in college
stations around the northeast
spearheaded by this station at wesleyan
university they're
dense and well connected it was a good
site for that
so these college djs they relied on a
sense of connectivity though with their
listeners
and believe that their status as music
fans as well as promoters of content
justified their free record service
but changes were happening in college
radio wnbr had long been a pipeline for
djs headed to commercial radio in
addition uh for musical acts that would
define popular music in the coming
decades
also in 1980
henry santoro you can hear him on
wgbh i think reading the news these days
uh henry cetera was doing a shift at
wmbr
the phone rang
and on the other end of the line came an
irish accented man's voice
i have this band here he explained i'm
not going to do the accent
they aren't auditoria and their record
isn't out but i'd like to show them a
radio station how it works we're going
to visit sure santoro replied why not
about an hour later a group of four
teenagers and their manager the man on
the phone
filed into the windowless station
you two
had yet to release their first album boy
which would produce no hit singles but
established the band's fan base in
ireland the uk
and on college radio in the united
states
whether this visit coincided with the
band's visit to wbcn that year where dj
carter allen
another wnbr alum and board member who
had moved to wbcn promoted the band that
remains unclear
in march 1981 the band did appear on
many other college radio stations kfjc
in san jose california for one
when they played a free show at san jose
state university
a listener there called the band fresh
and the band recognized that college
radio stations played music that was
quote real
real rock fans
turned to the left of the dial
college radio stations even if amateur
and non-commercial though confronted
questions of listenership and service
university administrators grew
increasingly interested in how their
institution sounded to wider communities
while openings for new types of
relevance emerged
the fcc encouraged college station
license holders to ensure stations
adhere to regulatory rules and serve the
public
and not use these higher increasingly
higher powered signals
as playthings or sandboxes as they were
often called
djs even those seeking careers in
broadcasting though still wanted to play
cool music
to wield cultural power and much of that
remained beneath the radar of commercial
radio
the fcc wasn't very cool
but it did influence college radio's
emerging culture and its ability to
break bands such as youtube to stardom
the fcc could indirectly shape these
non-commercial stations despite their
educational purpose and institutional
homes
a diverse
landscape of college radio remained
populated by many small stations each
doing their own thing maintaining their
own islands of influence
even though coordination and attention
was beginning to emerge sorry this is
pulled from the pages of cmj so it's a
little grainy
but cmj's debut which cnx are from here
helps to validate college radio as a
decentralized but powerful network with
coherent musical influence
but still questions about college
radio's direction and its status as
gatekeepers and taste makers remained
even as these conflicts over record
service faded
these djs felt that they had a more
authentic connection over music that set
them apart from commercial broadcasters
and that sense of being an outlet for
the people
a media democracy
simultaneously filtered into debates
regarding college radio's role in the
commercial music industry
episode three
there's the block schedule
so by the late 1970s and early 1980s
harvard and mit both pursued
controversial urban renewal efforts
with uncertain results
in 1980 the buy dole act allowed
universities to reap financial awards
through licensing federally funded
research innovation
rather than having to allow research to
be publicly available institutions
shifted to what one historian called an
entrepreneurial financially risky and
philanthropically inclined financial
model
this shift came with implications for
residents of de-industrializing cities
transforming to the service and
information economy working-class
neighborhoods surrounding the most
surrounding and suffering from these
transitions often felt that their voices
were unheard in these processes
and that extended to these radio signals
so at wnbr
a debate over community service flared
in 1980 in this context and as these djs
begin to consider the meaning of college
radio itself
city residents were blocking mit's
expansion into east cambridge as the
university pursued collaborations in
biotech and alignments with private
industry to revitalize the kenmore
square area
but the radio station
reached widely into these communities
unimpeded except by the limits of its
signal
conflict emerged over a new schedule
that cut community-oriented programs and
increased opportunities for students
a dj charged that these decisions
commenced without a good sense of who
the audience was
he argued wnbr needed market research to
develop a more concrete idea of who our
listeners are to better serve them
so this kind of market-based rhetoric
reflects this new logic of universities
community involvement and these urban
improvements
often displacing residents who lacked
resources in power
yet it also reflected the station's
sense of community obligation and its
commitment to public service
so audiences put up with a program that
underwent wholesale changes
there we go the block program
uh
wholesale changes three times a year as
student schedules change you go from
semester semester
and they still tuned in
but some teachers felt that block
programming and these frequent schedule
changes sparked a philosophic problem as
one dj put it we lost our commitment to
diversity some years ago when we
instituted block programming the
structure chopped up time into discrete
units rather than creating continuous
programs
blocks allowed djs to stick to their
interests
and it siloed listeners went the
argument
rather than expanding musical coverage
or exposing listeners to more than niche
sounds
he proposed wmbr staffers rededicate
ourselves to diver to diversity and
recommit to presenting shows and ideas
not heard elsewhere in boston radio even
if it means breaking up some of these
program blocks
so a movement to remove the program
director grew out of this
dissatisfaction motivated by these
program changes that went forward
without consulting affected djs
22 volunteers met
with 14 voting no confidence in the
program director they didn't have a
quorum so they couldn't they'd have the
power of removal
but even if it didn't reflect a quorum
it suggested dissatisfaction with
student managers among the community djs
in particular
dj dan gerwertz a future music writer
for the boston herald explained the vote
was clearly saying many of us are sick
and tired of the arbitrary power the
role of program director wields around
here
each program director might take the
station in new directions djs had no
mechanism to control the power and
limits of the job he said
the general manager appointed the
program director it was not an elected
position
and therein laid the problem
the system growths maintained
was undemocratic
and violated
the core principles of college radio
instead he proposed a year-round
schedule with major changes
subject to state uh state statewide
station-wide there we go discussion
he wrote i am in favor of democracy if
we can't have democracy work in an
all-volunteer people's radio station
where can it work
college radio couldn't make it work
the democratic media was not possible
some doubted participatory democracy
could produce a schedule though when it
came to democracy one dj wrote the
perfect example is a lynch mob an
oligarchy an oligarchy and tyranny could
easily result from a purportedly
democratic system
another dj called using democratic
practices to shape a program
a cute idea but extremely inefficient
she continued to imagine what would
happen if we needed to get consensus on
a schedule we'd be off the air until
but who exactly
were the citizens of wnbr
was it the djs
mit students whose facilities housed the
studio
residents of boston and cambridge
these dynamics these questions mirrored
uh urban development proponents and
opponents arguments regarding mit's
expansion
these were private institutions for the
most part occupying and influencing
public space
how they answered for their service
however was complicated and many of
those involved felt marginalized
so this debate over programming involved
deep questions about the viability of
community radio run through institutions
like mit
and sustaining democratic media
especially when many of these people saw
institutions like mit more as rivals
than allies amid conflicts over urban
real estate both oral and physical
meanwhile
that's part of the book
station business continued a beagle
wandered into the studio
dj put a call for his adoption a dj
reported on development issues fielding
calls from world bank staffers
some enterprising volunteers took it
upon themselves to reorganize the record
library flushed records that received no
airtime
control knob
appeared to be adding audio distortion
to a studio device
there's lots of debates over whether you
should put more jolt or coke in the
station machines a big deal
but the battle
as one dj called it continued
she called the new program schedule
method screwed because the same problems
reoccurred with each round
a poor management system she concluded
not poor managers must be the problem
a system developed under a 10 watt
mentality
did not transfer well to higher wattage
that reached a wider range of listeners
but the controversy grew tiring for what
it's worth she concluded i'm sick of
this
eventually one of wnbr's most famous djs
weighed in
oedipus the first punk rock radio dj in
the country by 1980 had moved from wnbr
to local commercial rock station wbcn
and to wnbr's board he stated
definitively wnbr is a democracy is
simple
station managers elect a general manager
who in turn appoints a program director
according to the constitution
vote out the general manager
to change things you don't like
a disgruntled dj resented oedipus for
his comments responding listen slughead
if you put in more time here at the
station especially at station meetings
we'd respect your comments
but the fact of the matter remained
wnbr's djs came from various walks of
life
some lived in dorms and could readily
volunteer or attend events and meetings
community djs had day jobs and had
trouble popping by the station to
organize the record library during their
free time
college radio whether a democracy or not
relied on volunteers to keep things
running and functioning
moreover rumors circulated that mit's
administration viewed the station with
distress
no i mentioned the reasons for this
which
is totally possible that this stemmed
from dj's publishing recommendations in
the student newspaper about which new
wave clubs carded laxley for beer
but djs interpreted the rumors as
relating to low student involvement and
the station's community orientation
the answer was to recruit more students
including grad students who might stick
around for a little bit longer
but college radio was a hot property by
the mid-1980s garnering attention for
its cutting-edge music and sonic
aesthetic setting trends that would
redefine pop culture and mtv in the
reagan era
as such it was not immune from culture
war battles over indecency and obscenity
with one station even rising to the
attention of tipperboer and the pmrc in
1986.
so
1980s epilogue
so by the 1980s
we have market
institution
culture warrior
all wanted to control
what went out over the collegiate
airwaves
at wnbr in 1987 the station revisited
tensions between student and community
volunteers
revisiting those debates from 1980
but now
in an increasingly fraught political and
cultural context
the controversy over four lovers only
the program was not despite surface
appearances though a culture war between
black and white musical forms and
audiences
nor was it necessarily about the content
of music on potential finds that would
threaten the station's financial
integrity instead the turmoil arose from
the multiple demands placed on college
stations in the 1980s
as more groups sought coverage from
collegiate signals
or at least sought to maintain the air
time that they had already secured amid
deregulation
programmers struggled to weigh these
demands they simply
had more applicants than they could
accommodate
nonetheless the effect was to silence
certain voices no matter the intent
so in fall of 1987 there's another
another instance of the block schedule
station managers are planning a new
schedule
and they gave djs notice to reapply for
their shows
four lovers only was a popular
long-standing community-run show that
highlighted r b from mostly black
artists
and it did not receive renewal because
it applied late
the producer of sugar shack another r b
program called canceling four lovers
only a slap in the face
the station relied on fundraising for
operating money if it's all right to go
to the community and ask them for money
to modernize this place he argued then
it should be station policy to serve
that community musically
sugar shack's producer referenced rising
criticism over the ghetto
the ghetto and four lovers only tended
to focus on r b and seoul unless on
hip-hop which is instead covered by
shows such as lekko's lemma which began
in 1985 and aired on both wnbr and wcvc
at boston college
but r b djs interpreted the cancellation
which proceeded after only two days
notice to submit for renewal
as signaling a desire to give students
more airtime at the expense of community
djs
students have made up less than 30
percent of programming staff during the
previous spring semester
still students supported the station's
community radio identity
one defended four lovers only denoting
that the debate involved questions of
what wmvr wants to be and what we
students want to do here they could
provide community service to mit
and our listeners
excuse me
and our listeners in the greater boston
area thanks to whom we're now in stereo
as they gave money
or we could jerk off in a vacuum
donations helped fund that upgrade in
broadcast equipment
and thus the student suggested
programmers owed listeners music they
wanted to hear whether it was mit
students tuning in or not
and if they didn't he implied they're
missing out on an education
but competing service demands and the
practicalities of running a radio
station created dissonance
responding to the charge that cuts
targeted black music programming the
music director tried to define diversity
as more than giving air time to black
artists
alternative radio he explained isn't
just black radio
these shows he argued received ample
time other than progressive rock he
continued black programming has the most
air time most of sunday both thursday
and friday nights are dedicated to black
music if you want to talk numbers he
said that's a pretty high percentage
the real reason for the cuts he
explained were scheduling conflicts a
show run by students took precedence
over community volunteers in a contested
time slot
the asset rather than complaining about
lack of communication community djs
attend meetings and read station
announcements
station participation was important
but these requirements potentially
undermine the priority of ensuring that
programming met community demands
and here's where you can find archived
tapes of lekko's lima at umass boston's
hip-hop archive
so in the wake of this deliberation
a dj cited recent regulatory
until the 1980s
the fcc promoted localism and diversity
and radio ownership
but rule changes removed limits on
multiple station ownership by single
entities
as the reagan administration relaxed
anti-trust rules
corporate acquisitions accelerated
across media industries led of course
by none other than ted turner the very
mogul who had purchased wnbr's formal
call letters to launch his media empire
public service requirements disappeared
as well
deregulation the mit dj suggested meant
it is no longer necessary for a radio
station to demonstrate that it will
serve the needs of the community to
which it broadcasts a core commitment of
wnbr
what all this boils down to he continued
is that with more and more restricted
lowest common denominator programming on
commercial stations becomes even more
important for a handful of
non-commercial stations to serve the
programming needs of the less entrenched
segments of our society
when you're in the archives and you're
looking for like the money quote where
like the historical subject says the
thing that you think is going on it's
like one of those jump up out of your
chair moments that quote was one of them
r b shows on wnbr
we're an institution in the black
community the dj argued and he lamented
petty station politics
it was a damn shame it's only two hours
the fcc
and deregulation
increased pressure on college stations
during the 1980s which remained locally
grounded
to air the voices of underserved
communities as commercial radio
corporatized
but institutional logics
governance structure and station mission
also
shaped wnbr's history as it shifted over
time
serving as a site for these deep debates
about regulation the business of media
and entertainment and the possibilities
for democratic radio
student and community djs might square
off over whose application took
precedent in a certain time spot
the real politics of college radio were
about much more
instead
the logic regarding structure of
programming the methods of governance
and financing
as well as station's occupation of
valuable spots
on public airwaves
combined to make these signals a key
battleground in institutional and
cultural change
no one can understand the multi-faceted
culture wars that continue to rage
without understanding the business and
politics
of these institutions
on the front lines
these campus stations were in the
crosshairs of government regulators
increasingly diverse sets of affluent
americans
and local communities underserved by
media in an era of austerity that was
already causing social services media
outlets and public spaces to contract
the culture wars are as pat robertson
declared a war for the soul of america
americans consumed much media about
these battles but communities and
college students participated
in the culture wars through local media
like college radio
so the culture wars revealed by college
radio and wnbr
involved a sound a war for the sound of
america and for the viability of
democratic media
i hit my ending target like one minute
thank you
so i can leave i have a little selection
of wnbr's top 30 from cmj and i can talk
about my my data project here and it's
very fuzzy which is i put up there for a
reason
uh so should i stop sharing my screen
okay
thanks to everyone online for hanging in
well thank you so much uh
catherine that was outstanding uh really
interesting stuff definitely a lot of
history i don't know i've only been on
the station for going on four years
well i do see that some of the people
listening uh including in their room
here have some
longer uh
good idea all right so katherine thank
you for the talk uh
as i was saying that i've only been on
the radio station for about four years
and so it's really fabulous uh to uh
uh to hear this history i mean it's it's
a remarkable story uh and uh the book is
still alive that's right although it's
taking a little hit during the covet uh
era
but uh the book is the first thing
you're introduced to i think as a new dj
um and what right what an amazing
document amazing things you found from
it uh so i just i have one question i'm
sure there are questions from the
audience as well and i can dive back in
with more uh but i'm really interested
to hear more about um
these questions of democracy uh and
and sort of the the role
this idea of alternative uh
so i i read this article in the boston
magazine i believe it was and i forget
the author but it made this very
striking argument for me about counter
culture uh and thinking about sort of
the counterculture of the 80s
particularly
and and boston used to be a hotbed of
counter culture and bob dylan comes up
here and joan baez and it was boston and
uh and and so there was there was this
sort of idea and then the article goes
on to argue that we've lost that you
know boston is no longer a center of
counter culture and why is that and
interviewing some of the different folks
who do organizing in town what used to
be known as
counter culture i'm i'm thinking of
alston pudding or these different
organizers of music events that
formerly would have been known as
counter culture but now
doesn't quite feel the same way and and
the argument that was made which i think
is kind of interesting and i don't know
what to make of it and partly because i
don't think so historically uh that's
why i'm very curious to hear your
opinion
but the the
the conclusion of the article as i
understood it is that
when you have the internet and when you
have access uh
to all the things that the the battles
of of the counter culture we talked to
the counter culture what was sort of
linked us back in the 80s a little bit
uh was the idea that we were being
force-fed
a narrow range of television a narrow
range of radio i grew up in a rural high
school in upstate new york we didn't
have we we actually did have a couple
college stations uh but even there you
felt like the like it was very hard
and so that
with a kind of dominant
mainstream media and without the
internet where one could somehow access
everything
there was the counter culture could sort
of fight together you know that it was a
time when punk and hip-hop were very
much on the same team in new ways you
know it said yeah they know they won't
play us on the radio they don't like us
they only play the older stuff
uh we can't get access and so there was
a way that these disparate things could
be lumped together under counterculture
but now when arguably i would say that
the media is even more powerful even
more forcing it down our throats
that the impetus that is it the image
that well i can still access what i want
on youtube i can still access what i
want somewhere else
for a while as i can still download it
on napster you know that there was a
kind of breakdown
uh
and a sort of breaking up of this this
group and that the the enemy is actually
stronger than ever but
but the
the idea that we don't need to fight
that battle is somehow broken up uh the
possible alliances that are there and
and i wonder what you think of that you
know is there something to that i know
you've been thinking about what is
alternative media what would what would
make a more democratic media
um
and and it is i suppose maybe that's
part of the question too is the
counterculture
done forever you know or or is there
something else
uh or is this not the way to think about
it so i i don't know there's a few
different things mixed in
confusingly in there so if you can make
something out of that question yeah well
i think so the question of aesthetics
okay kind of runs throughout this and
there's this idea that you know so
something counter cultural has this sort
of aesthetic
juxtaposit you know it's different
somehow it's you know it's weird music
that nobody wants to hear and like if
you have this sort of community of
people who understand something
that you know
most people won't and so there's a kind
of community of belonging around
aesthetic but when you actually dig into
terms like alternative
and where they come from so in the 70s
frequently the term alternative comes up
probably even more so than progressive
when it comes to college and community
radio
and but it wasn't an aesthetic
definition
it was just we're offering things that
the commercial media
won't play because it doesn't fit
through that
the model that they have or you know and
that's
as this commercial radio radio formats
we're starting to identify by kind of
demographic subset for fragmenting and
in that process of fragmentation they're
kind of leaving these pieces out that
were underserved and so you know the of
the 1980s it's you know it sort of
starts to develop an aesthetic
association
with
post-punk
hip-hop you know and that they
but it's really they aren't aligned
along an aesthetic
counteraction to the mainstream industry
even though
it's there right that's important
because it's very important you know the
green haired freaks hanging out the
radio station they look different they
sound different they want to hear
different things
the structure of media that they're sort
of engaging with through the language of
aesthetics is sort of what's what's
happening in the counterculture of of
the 1980s and you know that question of
access is
so
present you know when i interviewed a
whole bunch of um musicians and they
were talking about you know how they
would um
they'd read about abandoned zine for
example you know like their friend would
give him a scene and in the after
chemistry class or something like did
you read about this oh i want to hear
what that's like all right let's drive
out into the country where we can sort
of pick up this college radio station
we'll call and we'll request it like
maybe we'll catch it and then you know
bring a reading we can record it and
then we'll have to have it on a tape and
then i can decide if when my parents
take me to the to the city next month
i can find an independent record store
maybe i'll go get a copy or i can write
in you know to discord records or
whatever and
they'll send me a copy of it that that
access question was really powerful
and i think it's so
you know when i could queue up any of
those records right now on my phone
those barriers have come down
but instead but i think the
the thing that connects across all of
those that unites sort of
counter-cultural idea
is the question of gatekeepers and
tastemakers and
i think one of the challenges that i've
run into is that a lot of people who are
participating in this
they this alternative ecosystem or these
scenes or these bohemian networks
whatever they're trying to create
alternative markets but they want
different systems of
distribution and remuneration for
artists and they're relying on different
you know literally different businesses
and informational networks than the
commercial music so there is that kind
of oppositional that it does sort of
there is this moment where
they are viable and artists can make a
living
you know or at least get by
through this alternative market
structure um
but they are erecting sort of a new
system of taste makers and and
gatekeepers in within that alternative
system that i think a lot of times in
the language that you see people talking
about the counter culture they sort of
resist that idea right it is that sort
of democratic like we're letting
everybody in but
you know sort of the meritocratic
part of that
does
creep in
um and so and that can end up being
sort of a wedge among those different
groups you know so
a lot of times one of the things i run
into is that you have at a college radio
station mostly white
station managers and i say we we love
rap and hip hop you know we're mixing
public enemy into their rotation but
we're not including black students as
part of station management to actually
like rethink the structure of
programming
and sort of who gets to control how
those access the airwaves are sort of
set up um just because they're not
thinking you know they're thinking
through their own sort of lens
and so i guess now that we have
everything you know i talked to a kexp
dj and they look at themselves more as
curators that was the term that they use
rather than gatekeepers and taste makers
because there's so much stuff out there
but we still need a way to kind of find
our
find the things that we like find our
aesthetics
within that
um and so i think you know
we won't go into the is college radio
dead question yet maybe but it's that's
kind of
part and parcel of that that bigger
question
great all right good i'm sure there are
other questions comments we can start in
the room and then uh please people
online
uh we would like to have
more discussion as what
we'll see
hey listen
you're crazy could you introduce
yourself
hi my name is amber and i'm a second
year student
thank you so much
so i was really interested in your like
images and those ideas are your sources
so i would want you to talk a little bit
more about like your research
methodology and how do you choose your
sources there's they were so varied
yeah yeah so
for in one sense the mit
book is really unique i think i even put
that in the slide in college radio
history because it gives me
longitudinal
access to one station
in a kind of coherent format over time
it's like finding the world's longest
email thread
but it's so
it is unique of any station that i've
been to
that has that kind of source
um
i'll find you know there will be they
call them jock books and some other
stations or something like that um you
also find you know one for like a year
or a couple years and they're always
like these really really vibrant
pictures of the conversations that are
happening in the station
um
and so
on the one hand so on the one hand the
wnbr source like really stands out is
really unique and that's what makes it a
great station for me to put together a
talk like this because i can get that
that picture for the most part though
the research is really fragmented
because i'm relying on college students
to put stuff in a box and send it to an
archive um or to you know not throw away
stuff or like not spill their jolt soda
all over program logs or something like
that so it can it can be very disjointed
um a lot of my
uh good quotes also come from student
newspapers uh which thankfully a lot of
them have been digitized which made the
research really uh easy to do and for
you know i was able to get lots of stuff
and you know call letters are pretty
easy to search for so so that kind of
eased the process for a lot of that um
but
you know in the book and they would put
in things like they would take a clip
like if they're covered in the boston
globe or something they'd paste the clip
in the book and then everybody would
like mark it up
um at w-u-o-g at uga there's a big fight
over their format and they the
administration instituted a manager that
they all hated and somebody like took
his picture and they were like pig like
over his picture so you know you get
this really like
i don't know why i mean organic kind of
picture of this of these kind of like in
the studio on the ground um
but
when it comes to trying to put together
a whole narrative of when you're trying
to tell the national history of college
radio
it's like a giant jigsaw puzzle
because i only have a couple of stations
like wnbr which is not going to touch on
every single issue anyways
where so i really wanted to have like a
cast of characters to tell the history
of college radio through you know like
10 stations or something but instead i
have like 60
because i have to like
piece together this and the book is way
too long
so if you end up with 60 stations how
did you
end up organizing yourself and figuring
out what your life would be
yeah my initial thoughts uh ended up not
handing out you know i thought i would
be like really mythical
methodical there we go you know i would
have a few like major market stations
and like public universities and private
universities and then small liberal arts
colleges and it ended up like i was just
sort of like
you know wide arm grab and put it in the
blender and like kind of see what came
out
um
you know i wish i could say that i stuck
to like some sort of method throughout
but instead i kind of
basically i had these little chunks of
stories i would just like kind of write
up these episodes like i put the talk
together today
i have this episode i'm just gonna write
it up for my sources
and you know i used to use the program
scrivener you know how you can like kind
of chop it up into these little pieces
on a cork board and so i just kind of
like gather them like these two
stories kind of go together like what's
going on there and then i'll kind of go
back into the context and sort of
uncover like oh it's really has to do
with this kind of regulatory shift and
so it's
it moves chronologically
and thematically at the same time so
there's 18 total chapters right now so
we'll see what happens in the final
final version of it but you know so the
first part which a lot of this um the
first episode of the uh
um the ghettos debut is actually in
the first book that sort of been chopped
off um so that's not actually in this
book but the other two episodes are um
and the four levels only probably not
going to be in there that's similar to
the 1980 debate um
but it is this that kind of like fluid
process of like
moving across different examples i try
to have some geographic diversity within
each and different types of institutions
um
but the distinction is between i thought
there would be huge differences between
like public and private universities
and it's almost almost no difference
it's so such a diverse
landscape and radio markets really play
a big role
in what the stations look like
so it's really hard to distinguish
between
um
public and
institutions i think we have a lot of
that's kind private
questions
but maybe i don't know if they're in the
chat one more in the q a area but see
things pop up
i saw someone asking there's a
there is a question from the chat here
uh
from uh deborah douglas thank you for
this question
oh that's right everybody okay thank you
here we go i'll try again so deborah
douglas asked a question and just came
to the host of the panelist so everybody
can't see it i will read it
uh there are a class of college stations
that have morphed into npr stations such
as wwr wxpn
how do these fit into your story thank
you different yeah
so npr's sort of the bad guy
this is my story
um and i say this is not because my
former station was basically sold to npr
um
but it's always sort of this like
giant in the room
for college administrators so a lot of
the college dj's don't aren't
necessarily aware of some of the things
that are going on um but
some of the hottest
fights in the book like picket lines and
like you know screaming like you get cut
paper faces like the whole thing um have
to do when administrators try to force
stations to adopt npr programming
and there's sort of there's a few sort
of waves of this there's one in the late
70s and there's one in in the late 80s
but
the really the key moment is i
referenced it a little bit in this talk
was is with this class d decision
because basically the national
association of educational broadcasters
which are behind a lot of big npr um
signals which are municipally owned like
the bbe easy in chicago's municipally
owned wnyc
um and then the wburs um
they
and the corporation for public
broadcasting were pushing to create this
national network and they relied on high
wattage
clear channel signals
and so what would happen is you would
have a 90.9
launch increase the wattage to 50 000
watts or whatever
and then out there in
the hinterlands it would hit this little
10 watt station and so it would impede
the coverage of these signals so they're
the ones who are pushed pressuring the
fcc to do away with those 10 watt
licenses
um but there is a sort of ironic effect
because they're basically saying you
have to upgrade to 100 watts or more
and
you know spend a lot of money and to
become a more sort of full-service
station
to survive if otherwise your signals are
gonna get obliterated
and what ends up happening is a lot of
stations upgrade
and so that you know increases this
visibility on college stations at this
moment where they're also playing all
this weird independent label music stuff
and reaching kids in the suburbs and so
it has a sort of ironic effect of sort
of
amplifying sort of
bohemian sound on on the radio
but npr it's always there and
i've had to kind of break off some of
the npr stuff because there's a whole
story to tell there over some battles or
whether these signals would become in vr
stations um so instead i've chosen to
sort of focus on what's going on mostly
in the studios
rather than kind of in these
administrative conversations but they're
definitely there
and they definitely make a lot of people
mad
i'd like to hear about the relationship
between the university's psychologists
and their stations their stations and
then kind of power dynamics
and
issues that the stations have in
relationship to electric administration
one sort of assumes that it's constantly
hostile and so on because you know
getting a plane
[Music]
yeah it really is all over the map you
know sometimes you have um students who
are pushing for these signals to be more
mainstream or to provide more
professional training they're saying you
know i came here to college to get a job
and you know this becomes an increasing
narrative over time you know so i want
professional experience i wanted to be
like working at a commercial station
where i can then go out into the field
and get a job and prove you know that i
have sales experience or or whatever
with a broadcasting program or a
journalism program sometimes it's the
faculty
i have a whole chapter on the university
of kansas
where uh steve ducey of fox news is an
alum of their radio show a radio station
from the 1970s um you know like really
professional like journalists you know
students you know prestigious journalism
program
um but then you know
lawrence has this whole
like crazy music scene and williams
burroughs is hanging around and like
it's like super you know bottle gardens
just great venues and
this touring circuit and so the station
starts you know to go progressive
but then the faculty in the 80s start to
say like oh whoa let's bring the station
in and there's a big fight and
you know there's
another picketing thing and an fcc fine
you know drama ensues so in that case
it's the faculty supported by a dean
but then in other situations you have
the administration
wanting to prove that it has you know
sort of this public service mindedness
and so they look to their radio station
that's where you get a lot of the push
for npr programming or
professionalization
i have a whole tag in zotero like
administrative takeovers a lot of times
what they would do is they would sort of
hand pick a student or a graduate
student to come in as a station manager
to kind of clean things up
and there would be particular moments
for this this happened usually
so the big moment is around 1980 when
stations are upgrading their signals
when they start to go progressive if
they were new wave
then there's another round of them
in the 1990s where you have stage
enclosures um
the
probably the most outrageous example of
an administration kind of going off the
rails and and closing the station
happens at duffel university on long
island
which if you know the lore is where
chuck d and a public enemy formed in the
early 1980s that you know they were all
college radio djs there
chuck d talked about it as
the place where he found his voice
and what ends up happening is these
these narratives over these college
stations really replicate these larger
higher education battles that we see
over the value of liberal arts
so you have on the one hand you know are
these stations laboratories for stations
for students to get professional
experience so they can go out and be
positive members of the workforce or are
they these places
where students engage in sort of liberal
arts inquiry as a student activity can
kind of go out and find their voice like
chucky said and discover new music
expanded horizons and create new culture
and
and so you see those the same kinds of
array of sides in that larger debate
over curricula
visited on these stations so in the in
the 90s a president there at adelphi
comes in and he has the sort of culture
wars you know western civilization i'm
going to defend to the cannon and what
is this radio station that's connected
to these community members and oh
they're black and they listen to hip-hop
and i don't think that sounds like
college
so i'm going to get rid of the station
and he shuts it down over
over about a year and and it's gone wba
no longer exists and it was this major
uh force sort of in popularizing
uh hip-hop and particularly into into
the suburbs in the 1980s run dmc hung
out there all the time and
dr dre of umtv racks was an alum and um
yeah the uh
the heiress to boycott gets basically
its own chapter
because again it kind of comes at that
crucial moment
when you have the class d decision
taking place
economic woes hitting the record
industry
and
all of a sudden all the majors are
instituting the service and and so it's
really so it's wesleyan is the the key
kind of at the center of that and
there's a sort of like reluctant music
director who's like well i guess i'm
gonna take this on
uh and and you know lead the charge and
it gets tons and tons of press and
attention
and you know
it is sort of interesting that it's like
focused on this one station i mean this
one record label when there were other
cuts happening
but i think it was because of that sort
of unique relationship that arista had
with college stations and the music that
it was offering um that it was sort of
kind of a prime a prime target for that
um but i would say is definitely one of
my favorite chapters
and the whole thing
lots of good quotes um but yeah so larry
let me into the studio and i sat on this
little wooden chair i was pregnant with
my third child while i was doing this
over the course of like four months and
so after a while like i couldn't fit the
book on my lap anymore
i had to like readjust it's like all of
a sudden all my photos change angle and
various things so it's very like kind of
visceral experiences saturday mornings
and usually back backwoods was on i
think while i was there so i got to
enjoy it backwards you briefly mentioned
the end of the fairness factor how or
did that decision impact california yes
i put that in for heather
okay it really it really didn't affect
college stations except there were a few
talk shows that were on college radio
and so but a lot of times the
conversation in those individual shows
didn't really end up in the records that
i was looking at um
there were a couple of
outrageous moments though with those
talk shows for some reason
in the late 1980s um
a bunch of college shoes i have at least
three instances that i found um decided
that it would be a great idea to debate
ku klux klan members on the air
um because you know like david duke was
sort of like rising resurgent kkk and so
they're like well we're gonna like do
our
service to public debate and put these
people on the air and defeat them and
show everybody how wrong they are
like really bad really bad idea and you
know
there was uh lots of pushback
unsurprisingly because of this
um
and you know but they sort of use that
kind of like fairness doctrine model for
like how they were thinking about it i
think or that was at least because that
was sort of in the news i think that was
also part of
their thinking
in the way that they were shaping those
debates um but what's really interesting
so one of the examples actually comes
from my alma mater station at vanderbilt
you know these two students are sort of
like it's like they're taking like a
conversation that happens in a classroom
where they're sort of trying out ideas
and planning it on the air
i think that was sort of what they were
what they were thinking about
um but they do this and they get like a
basically a slap on the wrist like you
know wrvu this is a terrible idea
but then about a year later um there's a
show
called 91 rap sorry as 91 soul becomes
91 wrap or spawns off 91 rap they have
this really popular hip-hop show this is
like 19 1989 1990.
um 91 rap is on the air they're having
you know a few people come by the
station there's sort of some partying
going on at a certain point some high
schoolers get on the mic and you know
then like there's some kind of conflict
and you know i think maybe an obscenity
went out over the airwaves
um stations shut down for three months
so the administration kind of like cut
flies it's like what's happening in the
station so it's like okay
so the station a year before
put literally kkk members on the air and
it was like
and now you have members of the local
black community associated with rap and
hip-hop
you know basically a a minor incident
happens i mean i don't know there's not
a whole lot of records about what
actually happened or what went out over
the air but there were no complaints or
there may be a few complaints but their
fcc license was never in jeopardy at all
so there's this kind of
disconnect in the way going back to
heather's question about administrations
and the way that they sort of handle
content
uh
and what these students are doing and
kind of the political content yeah this
is kind of an incoherent thought but you
know bringing up the fairness back in
relationship to college radio makes me
think about the sort of notion that
fairness doctrine is dealing with you
know political speech
and then the other kind of place that's
regulated is indecency and that's just
using dirty words and so on right so
right um but if college radio is you
know often playing really politically
radical music
like
you could imagine them a college radio
station constantly playing say
anti-nixon type songs or anti-vietnam
songs or
anti-raven songs still relevant because
he doesn't get rid of the fairness act
until like 1986 so six years of constant
anti-reagan you know
punk rock or whatever right and that's
never going to be pointed to as is
unfair speech
because it's entertainment and it's not
going to be seen as content in the way
that a talk show if they were constantly
doing talk shows or auntie reagan they
might be subject to fairness doctor
complaints so i'm just wondering if you
see any
you know in moments where the music is
taken seriously as political speech
in terms of how the administration's
looked at it obviously the
people playing the music understand his
political speech in some way but just
sort of how that played out maybe one
story even that played out yeah they
definitely see you know that's the whole
like left of the dial identity and that
there's a sort of like progressive
political identity that comes sort of
with the cultural
part of college radio as well as the
political
associations that it might have
um
you know there i mean and the the
station that does get in trouble with
the pmrc is um
the uc santa barbara station and they
don't get fined but they get reprimanded
along with howard stern and uh kbfk the
pacifica station and so there is and
particularly in the 1970s uh you know
there's a lot of times um station
managers who come from pacifica and are
sort of creating those sort of ties uh
georgetown station for one um it gets
sold because
they're airing anti-abortion i mean
abortion um
uh services you know planned parenthood
clinics uh psas on their station so a
lot of times where you get that
political conversations is you know not
with talk shows but with kind of the
activist orientation of some of the
programs
um or the associations that they have
wrvu for one had a show that ran
throughout the 1990s into the 2000s by
dj ron who's a lovely person um called
out of the closet on the buckle of the
bible belt you know in in the 90s and it
was pretty controversial that he was he
was doing that and he got a lot of
pushback on campus
from that um
a lot of stations were very supportive
of anti-apartheid protests which is sort
of an often overlooked aspect of student
protests in the 1980s that like there's
sort of like apathetic student
you know idea like after the
counterculture uh totally not true total
myth um and that that sort of one area
um but instead where it comes out
really on campus and where you see the
most pushback there's something in my
eye uh is
they critique it through aesthetics
they're saying like this is like crappy
music that nobody wants to listen to and
you know what are you doing with my
student fees like i want to hear
you know stuff that that i like and so a
lot of the the sort of content
discussions get sort of filtered through
fee structures and governance and sort
of these institutional arrangements and
institutional politics which is why the
governance structure of these stations
even though it's like you know it's not
as much fun as like talking about like
you know
black flag lyrics or something but it's
it's
that's really where the rubber meets the
road
is over these sort of you know bread and
butter issues of funding and
bylaws and constitutional arrangements
thank you
i i just like to say thank you
you know it was a fabulous talk i i
learned so much about this radio station
that it seems very
humble in the basement of a problematic
building across the street here and uh
it's just absolutely fascinating to hear
uh this book project sounds fabulous is
there a
a timeline when we might think about the
book it is on the verge of going out for
peer review it is a complete manuscript
it is there i'm in the cutting of words
process and like i said there is a
second book that i had to chop off from
the beginning which is sort of the 60s
and 70s counterculture years is our free
speech on campus
uh kind of lens of on student media um
but hopefully within a year we will be
having book talk type
conversations thank you so much for
having me thank you so much kevin i'm
just going to close out with a plug for
next week good idea will be 100 virtual
next week on zoom uh and it's going to
be with raquel gates who's a professor
from columbia university and she's going
to present her experience working as a
consulting producer on the criterion
release of the melvin then people's
essential films collection so that's
going to be really really interesting
really
important stuff that she did there so
i'm just saying that and again thank you
so much one final round really thank you
and thank you everyone online for coming
thank you for all of our online
and see you next week awesome thank you
so much